down here in lower Manhattan it is the
one year anniversary of Occupy Wall
Street let's see what's going on this is
the one year anniversary of Occupy Wall
Street how do you think the movements
gone in the last year what specifically
have you guys accomplished some things
that we've figured out is how to provide
support to each other to prevent arrests
yeah how to support each other when
people have been arrested this is the
phone number for the nlg which is the
National Lawyers Guild anyone that's
arrested while here is to call them
pretty much as soon as they get there
what has occupy accomplished one of the
big accomplishments been there's
actually a website called what the [ __ ]
has occupied done calm and you can get
hundreds of things that occupies done
personally the biggest accomplishment is
is just making a presence I mean
everyone know it's a household word now
there was the move your money campaign
have moved billions I think it might
have been into the billion millions into
the billions of dollars from big banks
into smaller banks credit unions it was
the recent permanent injunction against
the portions of the National Defense the
National Defense Authorization Act that
would allow for indefinite detentions
occupier DAA yes NDAA that's Chris
Hedges the head of that lawsuit
occupiers are plaintiffs in that lawsuit
have you been able to get occupy
candidates elected or at least on the
ballot to me I personally believe and I
think a lot of folks in occupied believe
about changing the conversation outside
of the electoral system what does that
mean like electing folks based on
consensus rather than on the act or
process we use now how do we unfuck the
world I think we start by getting money
out of politics yeah overturning
citizens united reinstating
glass-steagall robin hood tax uh
president obama have you been supportive
of Occupy Wall Street absolutely not the
only thing I have to say the
corporations are people my friend and
they are the people and we are the pets
in here
they're the people and you're the pets
yeah we are Wow cracked my part yeah
don't frack any pugs don't frack any
people don't wreck your mother that's
John Lennon song I was very inspired by
that occupies heart is in the right
place I think it is but I I think they
need a little guidance in the writing
they do tune they need a little guidance
and they got a little lost along the way
they did they did now I mean I look
around and I see some people who
probably aren't working right now it
kind of bothers me that you have to sell
your soul to something in this world all
right so uh woody what do you stand here
with I have 130,000 for a PhD and can't
find a job now I think that the pole
problem is that tuition is allowed to
rise indefinitely because of this huge
debt system yeah you know part of that
has to do with federally funded student
loans all right thank you have a nice
day libertarians are awesome and you
know it no you're just intellectually
inconsistent anarchists
Oh